all right thank you all for coming
tonight I really appreciate it I'm
Ludmilla yonder people a lot of people
call me Luda and I'm a data scientist at
amplify amplify as an education
publication or publishing company we
focus on K through 8 and we have print
based online and hands-on materials for
students and I focus on our science
product so that's why I have amplified
science up here I think it's really fun
and great and I I mainly play a lot with
our clickstream data so looking at how
students and teachers are using our
product and so just in case the title
was confusing to anyone I wanted to make
sure to find to define glow-up as you
know it's something that the youth are
saying these days and it's a play on the
word grow up but you're glowing you know
you're getting better and I think
nothing better defines that than this
wonderful series of images and I you
know it's a digi plot talk so we have to
reference sadly at least once if not
more as much as possible so I thought I
would start with that so it's
essentially the purpose of this talk is
to show you ways to make your graphs
look spiffy and nice using GD plot and
some ggplot adjacent packages and then
I'm gonna go into showing some really
cool submissions that have been done to
tidy Tuesday and some of the things that
people did in order to make those
submissions so let's go ahead and get
started so what is my motivation here
about a year ago I was kind of new to
our stats Twitter and someone really
famous in the date of his world Edward
Tufte tweeted this out and I think it
was essentially more trying to say like
you can't make perfect graphs in our
because of annotation but in general
people took it as like
you know you just can't make great
graphs in our and your you have to do
other things as well and then all these
people started tweeting out really cool
data visualizations in response with
like nice annotations and things um so I
tweeted a joke about this thing was
Tufte just trying to get the world to
show their really cool visualizations
that they made an are right and I was
retweeting ba Brutus's graph that he
made that where he was saying well you
know it's a shame that Tufte said it's
impossible to do these do this with just
our I guess I should delete my blog post
right and and a lot of people tweeted
really cool visualizations and around
this time I started kind of seeing all
these possibilities with ggplot I think
I wasn't new to are at that point but I
was kind of getting this point where I
was starting to be able to make more
advanced visualizations um you know in
various ways so um what's interesting is
that after that little tweet with that
got 31 likes a bunch of us got blocked
by Tufte I don't know he's a grump we
got to see some really cool
visualizations as a result of this one
tweet so you know one of the real great
powers of art is actually visualization
you'll hear that argued all the time
right but what I find really interesting
is although that's the case graphs like
this absolutely persist right we see
them everywhere we see the graph and
immediately we know is main and ggplot
because we see that default gray
background with
major gridlines and you know arguably
kind of small axes labels you know
things that people like to say we can
improve so I think the best thing you
can do you know that's super easy if you
just don't want to do anything else
it's just use another one of the themes
that come straight out of ggplot you
don't even have to load a package so we
can already make this book so much nicer
by using a simple theme like this theme
minimal I love it and use it all the
time
so I think that's you know something
super simple you can do to already make
your graph look much nicer but something
else you can do and especially in a
workplace this is a really nice move is
you can make your own theme if you type
you know question mark theme you'll see
all of the things that you can edit
about a theme and you might feel super
overwhelmed because absolutely
everything on a graph can be changed in
some way in terms of size color shape
absolutely like the options feel endless
but often there's a small group of
things that you're actually going to
want to change so they're a you know
often you're gonna want to change the
size of the axes labels the the text and
maybe add some different color add some
different fonts so if you'll indulge me
I mean a playing a little bit with the
Diamonds data set so I use this luminary
fun and some color you know sky blue and
gold you know really not the best
actually looking thing but I think it's
kind of fun so here I applied the sea
and already my graph is looking you know
a little shinier a little glowy or
whatever um
so now I want to start moving into
talking about different graphs you can
make right a lot of us default to making
a boxplot when we want to look at
distributions by some categorical
variable and I get it it's what we're
all taught but I think there are a lot
of other better options so oh sorry just
to back up one thing I wanted to say is
another thing you can add to to make
your plot just look a lot nicer is to
just add commas when you have thousands
places like it makes them much more
readable using the scales package and
then using this label equal to comma so
yeah so anyway so we can use we can find
other ways to visualize distributions
one thing that people tend to go to is
the dot pas which I like I think it's
really nice option and it lets you start
seeing some kind of nuances in the data
that you don't see as easily with the
box plot right but one thing that I feel
like for me I always get a little
confused when I look at these I think
we're not used to thinking about
distributions and this kind of split
symmetrically funny way and also in this
orientation and so often I'll think like
oh the wider the spread that's like
bigger variance around something I don't
know I think that looking at these
visualizations can be a little confusing
so something that I really like to use
is the GG rigid package and I find that
super super nice for showing visuals for
visualizing distributions and one thing
I want to point out is that as soon as
we see this we start seeing something
really different than we saw with the
dot plot or the box plot we see that a
couple of these cuts have kind of
bimodal distributions
and for me that's super useful I work
with education data a lot so you know if
I'm looking at test scores a bimodal
distribution is something that's
concerning so it's really nice to be
able to see something like that and this
this package is awesome you can do so
many things with it like for instance
you can do something simple like this
like add a median line which is really
useful visually you can color the color
the distributions by color here I just
cut it off to the price being in 2002
kind of see this color but I've seen
this used in really cool ways one was
with weather over months and you could
you know see the the color really added
a really nice effect you could see that
temperature really popping out so I
think this is really nice option and
here I'm gonna point out I'm using the
verities package which is a really nice
package to use for colors because it is
really colorblind friendly it has a lot
of different options it does a good job
representing spectrums of data and like
letting you see them without using this
like you know default rainbow spectrum
that a lot of people use so I think it's
a great option um here's another example
you can color by the quantiles and you
know you can just do a lot with this one
I think it's really fun another thing
you can do that I really like is adding
this rug that's actually every single
observation I think this is really nice
because sometimes it can be really you
can realize that oh I have a really
sparse number of observations in some
area or um I think this is cool you know
we see that we don't have a lot of
observations at the higher price range
for the fare cut but we still have a lot
of ideal another thing that really
popped out at me is that there really
aren't any
observations here for any of the cuts
around $1,500 so this is a mystery you
guys should go out and find out why that
is I don't know yet I just made these
slides and noticed that I was like whoa
that's interesting I wonder what it is
is there something wrong with this
diamonds dataset that we've all been
using all this time anyway so one last
thing that I wanted to show you this is
called a raincloud plot I think it's
really fun because it shows both the
distribution you can add a point for the
median here I have a half a standard
deviation going out either way because
otherwise one standard deviation like
extended way past zero and I just
thought it would be easier to show like
this I think this is really cool and I
by the way I've included links to all of
these in my slides and my slides will be
on github this is not an actual package
at this point but I'm using a blog post
with someone made about how to do this
though it's really cool so I think it's
a nice option and it's actually not too
hard to implement alright so this is
that you can see this is this is
essentially the code for it
this GM flat violin is something that
someone made it's not in a package at
this point I don't believe you know
correct me if I'm wrong but you're
essentially using that and a couple
other jion's in order to achieve this
plot so I think it's pretty cool so now
I want to move on to time to talking a
bit about tidy Tuesday and showing some
cool visualizations from tidy Tuesday so
tidy Tuesday is kind of led by the r32
science community
and on Mondays I believe actually
they'll post data and then on Tuesday
people will tweet out really cool
visualizations that they've made and
I've learned a ton from following it on
Twitter and just getting to see what
people come up with not just in terms of
visualization even but also in terms of
data cleaning and even what kinds of
questions come up people come up with
with the data I think it's really
interesting what people have done and
then there's this really fun shiny app
actually that is just tiny Tuesday doubt
rocks that you can choose the data set
that you're interested in and then you
can sort by most likes most retweets
most recent and see lots of things so
this is how I stumbled upon this really
cool graph from that B from Gil and
Rica's who made this really fun
visualization of the number of guest
stars in the Simpsons per season and
what I think is really really cool about
this graph is that you know this is just
a really simple wrap right it's just a
line graph with some dots but it looks
amazing right because he's been able to
use a really cool font and just layer it
on top of a fun image and it like
immediately is a completely different
graph totally how to glow up right and
also I want to point out that a lot of
people will add their Twitter handle as
a caption on these graphs I think that's
a really good idea you know gets your
name out there and it's nice to see an
easy to credit if you want to use it a
talk or something like that so yeah I
just want to point out here that the
girl use the do G and
in order to superimpose the graph over
the image and another really cool thing
is I don't show it in the code here but
they also found a way to make the lines
look hand-drawn by kind of jittering
them I thought that was really cool
really creative the code is all honest
github so I want to clean out that
there's a another really cool package
for image manipulation that I really
like that's Jewish called magic using
this image magic approach that I've
actually used this package a bit for
deep learning like image pre-processing
it's really useful for that as well but
it lets you make these composite images
that are really fun so this was actually
an example from their vignette but I put
my put myself in this tunnel of data but
you can also make really nice images
like this you can put text on the images
which is really nice so like you know
and Jared tells you like three weeks
before it talked like hey I heard you're
the September speaker for the Meetup you
can make an image kind of you know
celebrating nice so I'm showing this to
you because you can also use image magic
to composite to put together graphs with
images and this was a graph that I made
actually for a tidy Tuesday and I just
you know you looked at the titles of all
the episodes
and just did a string search to see how
many episodes there were for each of
these main characters and we see that
Homer takes the lead and then you can
you know here I added this fun image
there are a couple of different ways
that you can do this this is the most
simple as simple as to just do this
image composite but they're kind of more
advanced ways to that don't that mean
you don't have to like save them a job
and then ya make a composite that way
but I think the Matt of the magic
package is really fun and cool and I
highly recommend it and then I wanted to
point up that you know just like that
line graph you can even just make a
pretty simple stack bar graph looks
super cool even just by picking a fun
font and a color package and there are a
lot of really great color packages this
is like actually a game of Thrones
package for this graph I used a TV
colors package that actually had like
the Simpsons main colors as a palette
and there's so many color palettes out
there these days you know that I think
it's really fun and I actually was in
the room with tomorrow and she made this
she got us together she's another our
lady in New York City she got a group of
us together on a Saturday and we played
with some tidy Tuesday data and made
graphs and I and highly recommend you
know like getting together with some
friends and making some cool
visualizations maybe not on a Saturday
morning but you know whenever you want
this was really fun to see and I also
really loved the title of this graph I
think it's really great when people use
these like action titles or titles that
pull some piece of insight from the
graph like this a goat named aria I mean
should I have admitted that to y'all
know is it Arya Jared doesn't watching
me haha okay good
uses the subtitle to explain what the
graph is right I think that's really
nice
so moving on so now I just want to talk
to you about a couple kind of do g-spot
adjacent packages so this is actually
now from tiding Tuesday but something
that I made based on something that I
made at work but the data that I use at
work is you know I can't use publicly so
this is completely simulated data but
imagine that these are students that
took a pre unit assessment and a post
unit assessment for each of these units
and just to be incredibly clear that
these are this is very fake data you can
see that these units are very made-up
and so I really like using the alluvial
graph in this case I find it really
useful because we can see the flow from
one state to another I will say that
sometimes they see alluvial graphs used
in way in ways or it's not exactly flow
from one state to another sometimes it
works but I think they really shine when
you're showing some movement from one
you know point to another and I love
this because I can immediately see that
you know for for instance for the
unicorn traits and reproduction a really
large amount of students started out at
level one but went all the way up to
level four whereas in potions you know
it was more a lot more on the students
just went over to level three not as
many got up to level four I'm able to
see these insights really easily and I
can explain this graph really well to
co-workers that aren't you know on the
data science team but want to see these
insights so I think it's incredibly
useful because it's it's super intuitive
and useful for people to see and I
wanted so I want to talk through how to
make it because I feel like the
vignettes aren't great and I spent like
a week trying to make my first one
and this is using the GG alluvial
package but I want to point out that
first you need to have your dataset kind
of wide by the this state that you want
to try the two states or however many
states that you want I'm saying state
you know like state of being or point or
whatever that you want to have basically
these things right and so if you start
with your dataset wide by that you can
use this ggl revealed two loads form
command and then it will pull together
and shape the data set as you need it
and it will actually label the columns
with the fancy labels that don't seem to
like make a lot of sense but are really
you know why do you end up seeing in the
code so I think that's nice so you have
the eluvian which is just the individual
or whatever that is flowing from one
state to another and you have the in
this case the assessment is that thing
that the state that doesn't get
relabeled but the struttin then you have
the stratum so those are those levels in
this case so then I go ahead and make
the graph here and then you see like my
kind of theme and stuff like that but
you can see at the top that you can just
set stratum to stratum alluvium to
alluvium Phil to stratum playable this
chatham like it's it's pretty
straightforward once you have the data
set in the right shape using that to
loads form function and it actually
makes it a pretty straightforward
I'm going to show you one more alluvial
graph I think this one was really cool I
saw it going around
Twitter recently this was made by David
News Earling and it was actually
tracking his experience in on the job
market so this is his first contact in
the first stage second stage and the
outcome of interview process right and
just for people that might not be able
to see in the back the yellow is ghosted
this kind of purple pink is no role
green is it got an offer
orange is rejected and blue is withdrew
so immediately we can see that there's a
lot of ghosting happening which you know
this isn't great
the other cool thing is that we can see
where we can track the offer all the way
back so it started out here on the job
site and then led to a phone call which
led to an interview which led to an
offer I think that's really cool in this
case I want to point out that there
weren't so many as you call them alluvia
so he was able to add this kind of gray
line around to really separate them out
in show and I think that that's that was
that's really useful for this
visualization versus mine where there
are a lot of students and not just you
just wouldn't see it but in that case
you're kind of seeing the flow from one
state to another so I think it you know
depending on the context it can work
either way but I really really like that
and so I want to point out once again
this is from his from his blog post and
he's he's also using this two loads form
in order to set everything up a little
bit different than mine just because you
know the visualization that's a little
bit different so there once again with
GGO revealed there are a lot of options
it's really cool package definitely
recommend playing around
it but for some reason often it gets
explained using this Titanic data set
it's confusing I don't know so I would
go I would actually look at this blog
post or my slides but these like this
actually made it much more easy for me
to understand how this was getting made
so now I'm gonna go back to a couple
cold ggplot sorry tidy Tuesday graphs
and and this brings us all the way back
round two tuff T's tweet because we're
starting a look at annotations and texts
and not just annotations with straight
lines but actually curved arrows which
is pretty cool and this was fully done
in our so this was the tidy Tuesday week
where they had game ratings video game
ratings are these are PC games and these
were the kind of top ten publishers and
then you have the meta score going from
0 to 100 on that x-axis so I think this
was really cool graph I really love that
the average by publisher is labeled as
well as the you know overall average and
then we see the worst game overall which
is rogue where I've heard that there's
some pretty funny videos of Rogue
Warrior haven't watched them yet I've
been preparing this talk but and then
the best games overall is that elders
for Elder Scrolls series of Skyrim right
so I think this is just a really fun
visualization and you know those
annotations are there they look great so
this is from Tonya Shapiro and this is I
will say that the annotations are a
little bit you you have to do a little
work to get them but this is only using
she uses this Gigi force with the GMO
that's the only non ggplot package she's
using just to make that circle around
the group of
games that are the Elder Scrolls series
and otherwise you can see like all these
annotations are written up and then she
sets the locations of all of the arrows
and adds them to the plot so I I don't
want to you know end this talk without
talking about Cedric shares amazing
visualizations these are just two of
them but like someone called him the
king of tidy Tuesday on Twitter actually
it was it was yeah I was Tanya and I
thought that was great so I thought I
would put that here and you know if you
want to see like the real power of what
you can do in are with like making
amazing you know visualizations this
these are great examples this was the
data set about birds bird collisions and
one about anime and you know I think
it's just really cool he has a blog too
just to see what he makes every week is
really impressive and really inspiring
and I think makes me really excited
about making my own data visualizations
in our so check him out for sure oh yeah
late great ad so this is a cool vakul
new package called GM point density that
lets you blend both a scatterplot and
get that density so i think that's
really cool this is a brand new mac
package so i thought i would just end it
out it at the end in order to include it
so in summary and if they change your
background you know if people can spot
that you made your graph in ggplot
because you have that default background
you can do better
you can do better super super super
easily right especially in a workplace
you can pick your work font and font and
kind of make those font sizes better you
can annotate away its have to be things
like you can do it it might be some work
but you can absolutely do it um so yeah
I use ggplot ggplot adjacent packages
like GG ridges gg alluvial oh I didn't
talk about do G highlight but that one
is really cool I have that one lets you
highlight just a specific part of the
graph and both even you know weathered
categorical variable or continuous and
it's really cool check it out you can
add images that really transform your
visualization I would suggest falling to
tidy Tuesday's I find it really
inspirational have fun eat some pie
don't make pie charts I don't know what
that's about
so big thank you to Samuel strain he's
my boss that amplify and he's taught me
a ton about making data visualizations
and also thank you to Sebastian he's my
partner go work with him a broom he's
awesome he actually inspired me to learn
art and I'm incredibly thankful I think
you know our ladies New York City I'm on
the board and I just so appreciate
everything that I've learned from being
part of our ladies it's just a really
awesome group thank you to Jared for
making me give this talk a thank you to
all the tidy Tuesday contributors
especially the people that I included
here
so kindly let me lift their code and
their images for inspiring me a lot of
people make really great visualizations
for tiny Tuesday and it's really fun and
exciting to watch and I so appreciate it
and thank you to the wider arts deaf
community such an amazing community I
you know feel so lucky to be part of it
and thank you all to for coming out
tonight
you have do you have any questions yes
yeah I wanted to say if you wanted to
see an example of GG highlight here's an
example I highlighted just the ideal
Shila did they deal with it yeah okay
sorry oh yeah it's tidy Tuesday dot
rocks which is easy to remember yeah
dang your fancy
that's impressive I love it that's great
I think the benefits so everyone heard
the question right here's the mic um I
think the benefit for me really is using
magic in ours just that I don't have to
leave our I'm like Jared I don't like to
leave our front anything you know tweet
email text yourself I don't know do
everything in our believe in that I like
it I'm also just not as fast I would say
with command-line and I think it's very
usable in our yeah I think it's who
knows why I only know that because I'm
Twitter um I so my joke was going to be
that she he leaves it like that to make
us want to change things like make our
own theme and change things I do think
some people have made the argument that
the gray does make some things stand out
a little better than having a white
background and to see that argument I
think that the problem is that it just
with the minor and major grid lines on
top of that it just starts looking a
little junky right so yeah I don't know
does anybody have an answer for that
doesn't even like have a line
but I think the patrols so it's like
respect to that I don't think have
leaves a path dependent guys I mean I'll
take it did what here yeah okay original
you know before are there was s and
apparently there they used trellis right
I'm feel terrible eyes totally neglected
y'all
[Laughter]
[Music]
now what's the best way to find packages
in the Gigi universe I mean what's the
best way to find packages in our in
general right it's like totally
overwhelming there's so many um like all
the good ones aren't on cran right now
I'm just kidding um so I think one thing
is tidy Tuesday actually you start
seeing like oh how did they do that oh
that's a cool package and you start
seeing that package getting used more
and more and you're like oh that's nice
oh that reminds me actually there is a
new our studio way to make alluvial
charts that they just put out um but I
didn't use it for this topic because I
found it all confusing and they used the
Titanic example again and I just didn't
have a lot of time to you know I'd
already made these graphs and I didn't
have a ton of time to delve into that
but there is I think Thomas Lynn
Peterson was the maker of that knew so
yeah anything that's like our studio and
Doris is often very reliable and then I
think looking you know seeing things on
tidy Tuesday and in general like
googling things you'll find good blogs
you really well you'll find like really
nice blog things like wow someone made
an amazing post about this thank you
yeah
[Music]
how look let's get it done y'all
it'sit's we won't have to look at
diamonds anymore I'll use pizza next
time yeah give it to give it to some
flock for tidy Tuesday
I think my and my own biggest limitation
cuz I am you know so I think it's pretty
limitless although I will you know
there's some things that can get
frustrating right like you make a figure
bigger and it makes the text smaller
when you save it out and like you're
just constantly rendering in trying to
change little things and it's not as
kind of straight out of the box or
immediately changeable as if you like
put an image into adobe illustrator and
start editing it right but at the same
time once you've written the code to do
it you can do it again and that's really
exciting like I lifted a bunch of slides
here from my own work or you know other
work that I've other talks I've given or
things like that and I and I often will
start making the same kind of chart or
the same thing and I can just lift the
code I have a theme I have themes
written for the work that I'm doing I
don't have to go into Adobe Illustrator
every time or something like that and
actually you know hand change things so
I think for reproducibility it's huge
obviously if you're doing a lot of
one-off things yeah there's a big
trade-off there I do I do think but I
think for a lot of us that are spending
a lot of time making visualizations and
are it I think it's I think it's pretty
limitless and pretty amazing and
powerful you just have to be willing to
like sit there and change the numbers
500 times to see what works perfectly
yeah yes thank you
yeah it's a good question so the only
pointer that I have that I learned
recently is that there's this Cairo type
that you can use to say skiing geez out
with really high resolution that's
really nice and that will also maintain
any funky fonts that you've embedded and
that's really cool I don't use shiny a
ton myself so I don't have any good
shiny tips does anyone have any good
shiny tips in terms of making your
visualizations look how like how you
want them I hear you though like I I
struggle with that a lot saving an image
out and then I open it somewhere else
and like my phone is gone or things
aren't the size the way that I kind of
wanted them to or resolution is a little
off and there there are some blog posts
about that but yeah I don't have a
perfect answer
yeah
yeah
so for if you look at my slides I said
the image size actually said the figure
with and then the figure aspect because
then it lets you use this like magic you
know proportion of their golden ratio
for like how a good rectangle sometimes
you need to break that but I saw I said
that in every chunk because sometimes I
needed to change that to make it look
better on the slide and then I said dpi
globally I'm pretty sure to try to bump
up the resolution without losing too
much but when you change dpi changes the
size of things it's like this whole
balancing act and then something you're
like crap I need to change my theme like
axes title size or whatever like it's it
yeah that is frustrating I will admit
[Music]
there's another question
oh yeah
yeah so sorry no the answer was just in
case you didn't hear it starting with
plotly and then moving from flatly to
shiny so you can see and flatly what it
looks what the graphs look like and
Polly's awesome I highly recommend it
yeah interactive graphs will always fill
the space available and shiny better
than GG Pottsville and i'm sorry i
didn't talk about integral active grass
at all or any of the digi animate work
that's being done at our studio that's
really cool because I don't really use
it but I'm sure that there are very good
use cases for it you know that aren't
like racing bar charts yeah
now that the kids are looking at my GG
plots but I wish they some maybe someday
No
so all my work is really working with
our product managers project managers to
get insights about our product how it's
being used
so no children are not looking at those
however we did if you're a new your car
you saw me talk about our unit that we
made where students middle schoolers
learn about data visualization and they
use a tool that we created that was very
much inspired by our and the tidy person
uses like tidy verbs and that's really
cool and also now at our studio they're
developing tidy blocks using the scratch
using kind of a scratch based interface
and it's very functional a guy should go
try it out play with it like show your
kids get your kids to use it because I
know Maya Ganso on that with her summer
internship at our studio it really wants
people to try it out and break it and
figure out what's wrong with it and like
you know write up issues and pull
requests and things like that so check
it out tidy blocks it's really cool
yeah yeah I think we all think it's
pretty cool yeah yeah for sure
cool any more questions yes
so definitely definitely just having a
theme to start off as your corporate you
know package so you can have your
corporate fonts your colors things like
that I'm not sure not sure exactly mean
by like
um yeah so you're thinking like you have
a big data science team and people are
making that all the same kind of graphs
and you want them to use other things
mm-hmm right yeah I mean my answer to
that is just make the graphs for someone
like we recently someone on our research
team wrote a white paper and I made a
bunch of graphs using our like company
fonts and made them look really spiffy
they may all been made on in Excel and
you know now we're working with the
marketing designer
and I think just like letting people see
like hey I can make all this super
easily I can change this immediately it
can change this color like I have the
code oh you want to change this data
somehow that's fine it's not a problem
like people will see that power and get
excited by that yeah
yeah so so cats talking about Bibi the
BBC put out a really cool what would you
call it like yeah it was amazing I'm
like all about using our to make data
visualizations the economists also uses
our and have their thei their own theme
and yeah Bloomberg like a lot of a lot
of big-name places now are using our and
have made extensive themes and not just
that but like guidebooks of how to make
visualizations what kind of
visualizations to use for what kinds of
data right like oh there's a
distribution use a rich plot or a dot
plot don't use the violin plot things
like that so that yeah that's really
true there are a couple of good options
I actually put the BBC one and I think I
put a link from that economist to as
resources additional resources in my
slides I have a couple like links to
additional things all right
[Applause]